guys before the video starts i'm trying
to raise three hundred thousand meals
for one thousand families in pakistan
yemen somalia bangladesh born sisters in
charlotte help us feed them this ramadan
to open and break their fast
i bet i'm just about getting to know her
i'd rather get to know her in marriage
as well
but if she's gone over my uncle my
auntie my grandma my grandmother
okay you want to get to know her uh just
about you've just about to get to know
her and you want to get to know more in
marriage but you don't introduce it to
your family
you've just you're in the losing end in
all angles
and that's why your hearts get broken
and this happens to men as well sister
brother sitting in this gathering it is
free mixing and this is my thing
no harm because sisters doesn't they
don't see the psychology
where i'm coming from i beg you any
money
and i'll get anybody to come and tell me
otherwise otherwise
why do i have to make them meet my
family why do i have to make them meet
their friends or whatever like oh that's
it there's so much pressure with that
anyway
i'm very different on it yeah
check out our sponsors nature's blend
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products the website is in
the description link below
you can also use the discount code salam
10
for 10 of their products assalamu
alaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends
today i'll be reacting to a discussion
amongst four people two brothers and two
sisters they're having a genuine
discussion about marriage
and dating before marriage and
introducing family and all kind of
other factors i wanted to react to this
because as you guys know i'm working on
a app
which is going to be helping young
people get married
but it's not matrimony so hold on a
second it's not much of any we're going
to people get married
you're going to find that very soon
we'll be working on that for the past
two and a half years one of the reasons
why the documentary is delayed
but brother and sisters inshallah it's
it will be groundbreaking because we saw
a
massive gap in the market and allah was
quite amazing figures involved as well
um which you're going to see inshallah
more brothers and sisters to make this
happen
the app is we can say done it's going to
be tested soon each other and then we're
going to upload the content
and you're going to have access to that
and in charlotte it's going to change
the way
um things work inshallah because
you find out you'll find that this video
is a very good reason for that but
anyways let's get straight into it here
we go and let's see what they have to
say
how long would you wait to before you
even get married like how long are you
going to wait on that
i think there should be a time frame
i'll just stop there there's most
certainly there should be a time frame
there's definitely should be a time but
let's understand where the where they're
coming from inshallah
and that's very formal you're
formalizing that's exactly what i'm
saying
when when you get like parents and
family involved that pressure's already
going to be there but with dating
and the other person look
from there it's ramadan we need to
assume the best yeah but there are there
if i just stop that there of context
maybe it does come across really wrong
you know it's just
me and you family pressure okay what
we're talking about here brother
we're talking about haram relationship
what we're talking about but no let's
assume the best inshallah
let's carry on but the statement stays a
bit like oh brother tell me what are you
trying to say though because
yeah yeah but then but it does get
hopefully it gets to a point
of to marriage didn't it i would be
happy to marry someone without getting
my family involved for
for a couple of years once again
once again it's um i'll assume the best
because in the context what he's trying
to say is that as a man
i'm assuming that he doesn't need to get
the wally involved he doesn't
well he he doesn't need his wally there
the the female does
but still again it's like why wouldn't
you get your family involved it is
alarm bells like if somebody said their
sister came to me there's a bro
there's a bit of what's their reason
behind that you know
but let's carry him why does my family
have to get involved
no because i bet i'm just about getting
to know her i'd rather get to know her
in
marriage as well but if she's going over
my uncle my auntie my grandma my
grandmother
okay you want to get to know her uh just
about you've just about to get to know
her and you want to get to know more in
marriage but you don't introduce it to
your family
why now the thing is once again i'm just
trying to be there with advocates
somebody can come and say
why you know because the thing is the
moment family is involved and this is
what's really beautiful about islam and
this is what i found amazing
in my marriage seeking process is that
the reason your family is involved is
because
if any party has wrong intentions there
are consequences where family members
have to answer to
and that is the reason why the biggest
con of dating where females are
sold into not literally but if you think
about it is
this concept of no wally not family
involved
from his side or your side yeah no mahr
there's no rights or financial rights
yeah um you
give him what he wants yeah he has his
own freedoms
you can do whatever he wants no
consequences if he decides to say
i don't think this is working out and
bye
you've just you're in the losing end in
all angles
and that's why your hearts get broken
and this happens to men as well
but what i'm trying to say is there's a
more a lot more to
a lot more to lose as a female so
getting family involved is
fundamental and yeah well let's carry on
inshallah
right how useful is it to like build
that relationship
but i'm like i want to get to know and i
think we made it a thing
even us we romanticized it a lot like
yeah like she gets to meet
family i think that's christmas
oh that's cool this is the correct the
christmas is eid um
the thing is it's not romanticized it's
islam this is what islam is
to introduce families to announce it if
you're thinking of haram relationship
you are not announcing it
in in marriage you have to announce it
people need to know
you know um which is very very um
uh important and one thing that needs to
be in mind and i need to make a
disclaimer look
i'm not here with these kind of things
to have a go at people yeah uh
i wanted to react to this video because
i found genuinely beneficial things
however we need to bear something in
mind these sisters and brothers sitting
in this
gathering it is free mixing now free
mixing will be like ah
here we go again i have to be real i'm a
man
i'm a man and this is my thing no harm
because sisters doesn't they don't see
the psychology where i'm coming from
i beg you any money and i get anybody to
come and tell me otherwise otherwise
these shows or like shows in context
where you know there's cause you need to
bear in mind there's a lot of
you know chatter chatter in the context
joking emotions
will be involved i promise
i promise you that if the if they were
to do this let's say
continuously or like over a couple of
months time where they're doing the show
again and again and again
trust me trust me
yeah and trust allah is messenger here
is
some kind of emotions are going to get
involved one way or another
if there's some kind of attraction
you're going to see it you are going to
sense
it and that is the reason why my dear
brother says he was watching i'm not
going to go at you guys please i'm not
genuine i'm not here today
it's not like i've got enough business
on the wall i never got people genuinely
if you do do this emotions will be moved
now let's picture
if all of these four people are married
how would their
couple their their their partners feel
about the discussion they're having i'm
not saying they're doing anything
inappropriately
but even if i was to know like my wife
is there having a little giggle chat
with a brother
or if a sister is there and seeing her
husband having a little giggle and chat
with a brother
even though it's like they're not saying
nothing inappropriately the point is
this guys
this is the tool for shaytan to slowly
plant that seed
right so i'm just letting you guys know
that we should refrain
that's just my advice take you i'm not
gonna look at anybody i'm just saying
well let's carry on
but i think like it's so important to
just like i think take a long in the
most healthiest way possible with that
person
that's what i've always said anyway why
do i have to
why it's a weird content why do i have
to make them meet my family why do i
have to make them meet their friends or
whatever like
oh that's it there's so much pressure
with that anyway like i'm very different
on it yeah
yes i think it's just it depends on the
individual that's what it is for me my
interesting even when i keep when i talk
to people about like whatever it might
be friends clients what i'm like
what's your views on like reclaim your
own meanings like what does it mean
truly for you to be happy for you to be
healthy that's what
life's about i don't think people
reflect yeah i don't think people
know that yeah
so the thing is it's very very important
in a marriage-seeking process
for family members to be involved it's
fundamental and crucial
uh because your family members are the
one that know you the best
it is fundamental that is the reason why
we're working on the app you know
because
mom and sisters you need to understand
there are so much cons
marrying the wrong person can be
devastating
absolutely i know of stories horror
stories which are covering the
documentary
of people not seeing their kids not
being allowed to see their kids
madness madness like the very person who
married the sister the brother who's
righteous
from the brain at night
will turn and use the british law
against you
things go very ugly so it's so
fundamental for you
to be very very wary to the person
you're getting
to know for marriage guys so fundamental
otherwise it costs so much that's why
family members are the best people
that know you i know my brother my
brother knows me
if he was my sister i know her you have
to come to me bro
you have to and islamically you need to
know that it's not backbites if i come
and see you you know my prophet doesn't
pray
if i was to say that for example you
know my brother or this that or my
sister
like this or she's got this or she got
anger problems i have to tell you that
i can't ruin your life you know and me
personally
i had that experience and you're going
to see in the documentary i had the
experience
i went through hell hell on
earth because i was warned and i didn't
listen you're gonna come you're gonna
find out
but the point is this it's so
fundamental to me to meet the family
so crucial so let's not undermine that
i feel like i think i think sometimes
because again
society pressures family cultural
ideology it's almost like a trend
nowadays about 20 years yeah we were
saying it was positive to get married
but for some people it's the worst thing
possibly do exactly i think it drives us
away i just
marriage is very i think it's very
individualistic man i don't think
there's this whole like
dating okay what about dating how long
would you date someone until you make it
so
okay so some people to say like you said
you know for some people it's the worst
thing to do
yeah it's very simple guys we're human
beings we have
we need a companion yeah that's what
adam is supposed to have created
so the the reason why allah is because
we have that need in the context i'm not
talking about the sexual i'm talking
about someone to have
a part of your life if you start a
family this is something that is amazing
which
the society and i would say you know
feminism
or you know other ideologies have
alienized
in the context where oh no career etc
it is there is nothing wrong to start a
family so anybody that
in their right state of mind especially
men
for them to feel like i'm not ready to
get married in your twenties or thirties
said there's few options here you're
either masturbating
yeah you're either committing zina
or i think say there's something wrong
with you i mean
which other freak because this is
marriage you you
it's it's like seeing oh i can i can go
without you know i don't know
food or what can i say i don't know
sleep in for
is so much where your body's gonna say
you need to sleep you need food
i know there's a diet situation with
death but i'm saying that you have to
you would need to get married otherwise
there's a question mark on you
what are you doing brav yeah i'm so
sorry same goes with sisters
what is the reason why what's stopping
you
is it that you already have something
that you call marriage which is a haram
relationship
um is that what's stopping you oh that's
why you want to go union carry on etc
especially with men they make excuses oh
we're still young
yeah we're still young let's see that
girl that you're in a harem relationship
with you who does not let you touch her
at all
until you marry her then let me see how
fast the process gets for you let's
quickly get married
um and brahmana says like i said before
i want you guys to inshallah be patient
uh soon inshallah i'm going to be
helping inshallah allah
young muslims into the marriage seeking
process
for a happily ever do not forget what i
just said those statements
because you're going to hear that a lot
we're preparing something massive and
insha'allah my aim is to
help people into the marriage seeking
process and not go for the mistakes me
and many other people made
and our lives were nearly ruined till
next time assalamu alaikum
how can we have so many devices with so
many apps which help us monitor our
progress for our body
but none for the soul well the qurani
app is about to show you your progress
with your soul
yes that's correct not only does it
encourage you to read it tells you how
many verses you've read how many pages
you read how long you've been on it and
best of all the hasanah counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah's book like you've
never had before